mike florio of pro football talk pro
football talk live which is the first
show to kick off nbc sports on peacock
every day and then pftpm
that's later on today on uh this great
streaming channel how are you mike
doing great rich how are you so let's
start with this what do you what do you
know about these tests
and the positives well you know the
league began the season
and went through the first five weeks of
the regular season without testing
players on game day
that's a fairly new dynamic and
what it shows us is there still is that
possibility that a guy can have a nasal
swab performed
on a sunday morning and they can get the
results on monday
and the conclusion will be if it's a
confirmed positive
that the player was positive for the
virus shedding virus
in the locker room before the game on
the field before the game on the field
during the game on the sideline during
the game and in the locker room after
the game which
now means for the ravens and for the
packers they have to hold their breath
and see
what may happen over the next few days
because of the incubation period and
rich one of the things the nfl realized
just in the past week
the sidelines present a greater risk in
the nfl's estimation
of spreading the virus then the field
does
no kidding because on the sideline you
see it all the time guys are sitting
right next to each other
extended stretches no masks and so the
nfl has recommended social distancing
and mask wearing on the sidelines but i
didn't see a lot of it yesterday
and that may be the next step in the
agreed protocols that it'll be mandatory
to distance and to wear masks on the
sidelines on game day now we all have to
hold our breath because again it's not
just the packers with the running back
aj dylan or the ravens with corner
marlon humphrey it's the steelers
um and also uh the vikings who have
dealt with this before
uh with another team that's tested
positive i was houston if i'm not
mistaken
that uh was involved with that or
another team of some sort uh earlier
this season but
uh there's also an early game this week
the packers
i mean the incubation period uh if
if we're talking about dylan potentially
spreading it around yesterday
might not um might not i guess come to
fruition before game day on thursday
and the one good thing for the nfl so
far the only data point you're referring
to that vikings game it was the titans
game week
titans were on the front end of their
outbreak there was no crossover
between titans players and vikings
players and the league has been very
confident rich
that in an open air setting on a
football field
even in a dome because they have
state-of-the-art ventilation systems
there that have been
engineered in advance in the event of an
air assault terrorist attack and they
don't talk about that
stuff much but the precautions are there
they believe the air can be cleaned out
quickly
and is cleaned out quickly and so it's
it's a far less of a risk than it is
being in a confined space so
they believe there won't be on the field
they don't believe guys are in enough
sustained contact to give it
to each other so we'll we'll see we have
one game from
five weeks ago where it could have
happened and it didn't and now we've got
two games from yesterday where it could
have happened and we'll see but but
you're right look we've got
a thursday night game what do you do do
you just go forward
and just as there are more positives
guys are knocked off of the lineup
and then you take the contacts out of
the loop as well
do you do everything you possibly can to
put people on the field on thursday
night and get that game in do they move
that game
to sunday or monday or tuesday
of of the following week i mean there's
some flexibility but not much
because the bye weeks are no longer an
option and
are for most teams and so you know at
some point if you're talking about a
postponement you're talking about an
18th week so
yeah these these are a bunch of issues
that are going to keep coming up until
there's a home market bubble
for 32 teams that is effective and it
keeps guys from testing positive
you're going to have people who go home
they go out to the community
the numbers are going up coast to coast
so
you're going to inevitably have guys who
get it when they're not at work
and i guess the last thing on this
subject matter is
so because i was you know very critical
that major league baseball would have a
world series game
where somebody tested inconclusive the
day before and then
found out that the test taken day of
game he was in fact coveted positive and
removed from a game in
in the seventh inning so are are we
saying that even though
nfl is testing every single day
including game day the fact that they're
taking these tests on game day and then
sending them elsewhere as opposed to
maybe having
a rapid test on site which might not be
as accurate
um that we're seeing potentially a
loophole here
where players uh could test positive and
you know play a game positive and we may
see somebody removed in the third
quarter of a game because of it
potentially you know i asked the league
last week after the dodgers game
whether or not it could happen that
there would be a test result that comes
back during a game and what would the
league do
the league said it's unlikely but it's
possible that that would happen and they
would
immediately remove from play a player if
they get the positive result back so
much of it though
and this is old-school low-tech how far
the van has to drive the samples to the
lab
or how far the plane has to fly i mean
it has nothing to do with the actual
testing technology
it's how long does it take to get the
sample into a spot where it can be
tested
so the closer the game site is to
the labs that the nfl has throughout the
country that that are handling these
samples
the less time for the turnaround and you
know it would have to be a night game
that the players for night games are
tested mid to late morning
so you get an eight o'clock start you
know an 8 30 start whatever the case may
be
that's when it potentially could happen
that that we would have a guy yanked in
the middle of the game and
the nfl is very confident that
if it's a championship game if it's a
super bowl
that the player will not find his way
out of the isolation room onto the field
to celebrate
his teammates and anyone else who may be
there the league is very confident that
they will not
see that happen and after we've seen it
with baseball the nfl can't say well we
never saw that one coming
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
host of pro football talk right here on
nba pro photo pro football talk live and
pft
p.m right here on nbc sports on peacock
and there's also of course his stellar
website and twitter account let's talk
about the um
the trade deadline a day away is there
anything popping
that you're hearing right now we know a
week ago the sense was any deals that
were going to happen would happen by
wednesday or thursday of last
week because of the covet 19 protocols
because of that five six days that you
have to wait to actually join a new team
you want to do the deal by thursday so
the player can then show up and practice
the following wednesday that's the first
major work day for a sunday game now
that we've gotten through that
and we're at the point where hey if you
do trade for somebody you're not going
to have in week nine
because of this this waiting period that
automatically kicks in even though the
guys are tested every day
on the team they come from it makes no
sense that that doesn't translate
it's the same tests it's the same
procedures but it still doesn't
translate
so now i think what we're going to see
is teams who understand
whoever we get we don't have the guy
until week 10. so maybe we give up less
than we would have given up to get him
and plus you have one more week of games
you have teams that maybe were thinking
about buyers like the lions they bought
last week with everson griffin maybe
they would have been thinking about
trying to get stephan gilmore from the
patriots if they had beaten the colts
yesterday
now they lost maybe they don't do it
team like the jets falls to 0.8
yesterday
avery williamson gets the all-time gift
of any holiday all of them rolled into
one to go from
0-8 to 7-0 in pittsburgh and he's
thrilled with that
you know not that the jets wouldn't have
done it if they'd won yesterday
but still having that one extra game
that one extra week that one extra
number in the win column or the loss
column
that really does help crystallize and
also injury remember the carson palmer
trade from 2011
broken collarbone for jason campbell
with the raiders
deadline two days later raiders give up
way too much for carson palmer so there
could be an injury tonight in the tampa
bay game
that causes the buccaneers to scramble
tomorrow to fill a need that may arise
in that game against the giants where do
you stand on the subject matter of
trevor lawrence
staying in school to avoid the jets
everybody's talking about that right now
i'd love to get your two cents on what
you're hearing and uh
and what your thoughts are on that mike
florian well rich i think going back to
clemson and playing for free
isn't the answer i think that
what you say is i don't want to play for
the jets
go ahead and do the john elway eli
manning thing i don't want to play for
the jets i don't want to play for the
jaguars i don't want to play for this
team i don't want to play for that team
and if you draft me i'm not going to
sign a contract and i'll sit out the
whole year
and you will have wasted that pick bo
jackson style
and i'll re-enter the draft next year
now the problem is you're always
at the mercy of being selected by the
worst organization in football that year
absent a trade or some kind of a fluke
where you fall down the board like lamar
jackson did
or like patrick mahomes did because the
guys who really
believed in patrick mahomes kept their
mouths shut and it didn't get out
that mahomes is the guy andy reed sean
payton mike mccarthy were the three who
were really on to patrick mahomes and
they they were discreet about it
you know this cast out of the bag on
trevor lawrence now maybe if he doesn't
play
next year others will emerge and he'll
slide down but still
you're always subject to that that
involuntary process
so i'm a big believer in guys pushing
back against the concept of them being
told where they're going to start their
nfl careers
they're allowed to pick which college
they go to i think they should be
allowed to pick which nfl team
they go to i know that would be a
subject that would fill up an entire
three hours oh my god you should go down
that rabbit hole
but i think that a guy who has leverage
a guy like a joe burrow
a guy like a trevor lawrence should be
willing to say
i don't want to go there it worked for
elway and eli not enough guys do it
and so the last thing he should do is go
back to clemson rich
what he should do if he doesn't like the
menu of options
of teams that may pick him make his
wishes known
privately publicly or both to avoid
playing where he doesn't want to play
well i guess the one way to handle it
would be to
to telegraph to him um sometime
um obviously when when there it's
obvious they're gonna get
uh the number one overall pick the jets
still have a lot more losing to do and
there are still some one-win teams hot
on their heels
um it would be to telegraph um
who's gonna be the next coach in a way
right i mean
that it's clearly not gonna be adam gase
who's
who's into whose hands trevor lawrence
is placed
why does he still have a gig right now
mike well i keep thinking that the bye
week is going to be the moment that it
happens and if it doesn't happen then
then i don't think it'll happen at any
point this season they've got one more
game against the patriots before they
enter their buy
they just look i feel bad for adam gays
the last
three years you know he took a team to
the playoffs in miami and then the 2017
season had the
ryan tannehill torn acl early in
training camp
and they had all sorts of schedule
changes they ended up burning their by
week one that year because of a
hurricane and played 16 straight games
and it was
and you know look everybody deals with
injuries and those things but it just
feels like it's
it's been a snowball that just keeps
building for gas wherever he is
it hasn't been good with the jets
they're not competitive we've talked
about this before with the panthers you
look at how they're playing
while they're rebuilding the jets are
just not competitive
it felt like they were a little
competitive yesterday until
you know patrick mahomes did patrick
holmes things and that was that
but but i just feel like it's it's got
to happen right it's kind of happened
during the bye week
and and my only hesitation is it's
always hard
for reasonable minds to predict the
behavior of unreasonable minds
and i just feel like that there are
unreasonable minds running the jets
and and so you know if christopher
johnson isn't willing to do it then it's
not going to happen
and if woody johnson isn't going to pick
up the phone and say what the hell are
you guys doing over there
make this move then it won't happen and
but but i agree with you rich
part of this is letting trevor
lawrence's people know
what's going to happen in new york in
2021 and there's
there's a window in you know early
january once it's clear
that the jets have quote unquote earned
the first pick there's a couple of weeks
before trevor lawrence has to make his
final commitment
so there can be some back channel
discussions about what he would like to
see
and whether or not the jets would be
willing to do it and then he's going to
have a decision to make do i
declare for the draft or do i not but i
still think he should and then continue
to work the process and if he doesn't
like
the outcome if he doesn't like who picks
him then just say i'm not showing up and
hope that that force is a trade
and be willing to sit out the whole year
if need be a couple more minutes left
with mike florio of pro
pro football talk right here on the rich
eisen show um
let's talk about miami it sure looks
like the coach there
knows exactly what he's doing and by
that i mean he he brought kind of the
belichick
brian flores game plan against the rams
and just kept hitting golf in the mouth
and that along with some special teams
play is what helped
with tool who looked like a rookie as
you might imagine against a defense like
that
but they're they seem positioned not
just for this year but with
draft choices galore because of the
texans
trade um they look to be well positioned
in miami would you agree with that mike
oh
absolutely rich and i think one of the
reasons you put two on the field is
there's a chance
the texans are going to be in position
to draft trevor lawrence
and that means you as the dolphins are
in position to draft trevor lawrence and
it could be the same thing the cardinals
went through a couple of years ago where
they
moved on from josh rosen after one
season because kyler murray fell into
their laps so
yeah absolutely i think they've got
something good going on
it wasn't touah yesterday he had 93
yards passing when you look at the
statistics
out of that game i've never seen a more
jarring difference 31 first downs for
the rams eight for the dolphins
471 net yards of offense
for the rams i think 150 for the
dolphins or something ridiculous like
that and you would have never dreamed
the dolphins would have won that game
but it was the defense it was brian
flores and this is something chris sims
was saying all week on pft live
flores was there in new england as they
got ready to play the rams in super bowl
53
he knew what to do to slow down that
offense and
uh they did it repeatedly they built the
lead and they held on so i like what
they're doing
but yeah they're going to need to see do
a tua eventually do something more than
he did yesterday i mean then next up is
uh kyla murray uh
in arizona um and that that's definitely
something i can't wait to see in week
nine before i let you go i'll just give
you an omnibus what's the story you're
looking at right now
that's developing or football wise over
the next few weeks that you're eager to
see
play out i mean i hate to go back to
where we started
but but i really do just kind of keep
constant watch
of where trends are moving with
the virus i'm amazed and i'm impressed
that the league has been able
to get through eight weeks and we'll
assume
knock on wood that tonight's game
doesn't get derailed by some
last minute positive test or last minute
outbreak but to get through eight weeks
and have all the games played now they
all weren't played when they were
supposed to be played but
they were all played i just i keep
worrying about
how that plays out over the next few
weeks and and
look rich i know sports is our haven
from all the other things we worry about
but
i worry about the aftermath of this
election whatever happens however long
it takes to resolve it
whatever the outcome may be does that
cross over into sports because one thing
we've seen this year
issues like that and the unrest that
follows can affect sports
and will there be some type of reaction
within football
depending upon whatever it is that
occurs tomorrow the next day the next
week the next month right
and one thing for sure i know you're
bringing it up here it sticks to stick
to sports is dead
uh with jack nicholas and jay cutler and
brett favre of making their preferences
known
in a manner that if other athletes did
um
it would be stick to sports straight
down uh the twitter feed stick to sports
is dead
and i didn't hear stick the sports went
far made his endorsement isn't that
weird maybe i just wasn't paying
attention that day it is
it is weird mike uh but hashtag stick to
sports to me is
is dead forevermore uh thanks for the
call mike uh
always appreciate catching up with you
and uh and you accepting the invitation
to come on and i look forward to pftpm
later on
and every single day pro football talk
live to kick things off here on nbc
sports on peacock 22 million subscribers
strong
it's good stuff thanks rich hey great
talking to you right back at you that's
mike florio
at pro football talk must uh must follow
must everything
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here